SAID HE HADN’T MADE A REQUEST
BUT WOULD SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THROUGH HIM BENJAMIN HALL,
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOVES A PARADE.
HE WAS SO IMPRESSED WITH
FRANCE’S BASTILLE DAY EVENT LAST
YEAR, HE WANTS ONE IN
WASHINGTON.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US THAT
MIGHT NOT BE SO EASY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME UP WITH
THE IDEA FOR MILITARY.
WHILE VISITING FRANCE DURING THE
BASTILLE DAY LAST JULY.
SEEING THE TANKS AND MILITARY
HARDWARE AND MARCHING SOLDIERS.
HE HAS WONDERED WHY THE U.S.
DOES NOT HAVE SUCH A MILITARY
PARADE.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT VISITED THE
PENTAGON ON JANUARY 18, HE
MENTIONED THE IDEA TO THE JOINT
CHIEFS.
THAT’S WHEN THE PENTAGON
REALIZED THIS WAS A DIRECTIVE.
>> WE ARE ALL AWARE IN THIS
COUNTRY OF THE PRESIDENTS
AFFECTION AND RESPECT FOR THE
MILITARY.
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER
SOME OPTIONS.
WE WILL SEND THEM UP TO THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR DECISION.
>> WE HAVEN’T MADE A FINAL
DECISION.
THE PRESIDENT IS EXPLORING
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT HE CAN
HIGHLIGHT AND SHOW THE PRIDE WE
HAVE IN THE MILITARY.
>> THE BLOWBACK FOR MILITARY
VETERANS AND DEMOCRATS WAS
IMMEDIATE.
WE  "DONALD TRUMP HAS SHOWN HIMF
TO HAVE AUTHORITARIAN TENDENCIES
AND THIS IS ANOTHER WORRISOME
EXAMPLE."
ADAM SMITH OF THE HOUSE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE CALLED IT
SELF-AGGRANDIZING AND A MISUSE
OF MILITARY TIME AND ENERGY.
>> IT IS NOT SOMETHING WE HAVE
DONE IN AMERICA.
>> MANY FEAR THE U.S. WILL LOOK
LIKE THE AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES.
NORTH KOREA, CHINA, RUSSIA.
THE TRADITION IN FRANCE IT DATES
BACK TO NAPOLEON.
REPUBLICANS PUSHED BACK.
>> IT’S REASONABLE FOR THE
NATION TO BE PATRIOTIC AND
CELEBRATE THE PEOPLE SERVING US,
THE 1% THAT SERVES OUR NATIONAL